essen
Ich esse einen Apfel.
Was isst du?
Er isst gesund.
Wir essen heute im Restaurant.
Esst ihr oft in einem Restaurant?
Sie essen in der Schule.
Ich habe im Restaurant gegessen.
öffnen
Ich öffne die E-Mail.
Öffnest du mir bitte die Tür?
Er öffnet den Brief.
Wir öffnen das Fenster.
Öffnet ihr die Geschenke?
Sie öffnen die Pakete.
Markus hat sein Weihnachtsgeschenk schon geöffnet.
lesen
Ich lese ein spannendes Buch.
Liest du oft Zeitung?
Monika liest ihre E-Mails jeden Tag.
Wir lesen die Nachrichten im Internet.
Lest ihr oft Bücher?
Sie lesen eine Zeitschrift.
Ich habe meine Nachrichten noch nicht gelesen.
fahren
Ich fahre mit dem Auto.
Du fährst mit dem Bus.
Er, sie, es fährt mit dem Zug.
Wir fahren mit der U-Bahn.
Ihr fahrt mit dem Velo.
Sie fahren mit der Seilbahn.
Ich fahre heute nach Bern.
Ich bin gestern nach Bern gefahren.
fernsehen
Ich sehe oft fern
Du siehst manchmal fern
Er, sie, es sieht selten fern
Wir sehen täglich fern
Ihr seht immer fern
Sie sehen gern fern.
Ich habe gestern Abend ferngesehen.
tanzen
Ich tanze in der Disco.
Tanzt du gern?
Er, sie, es tanzt an der Hochzeit.
Wir tanzen im Restaurant
Tanzt ihr oft?
Sie tanzen immer.
Ich habe in der Disco getanzt.
mögen
Ich mag Fussball.
Magst du Eishockey?
Er, Sie, Es mag keine Tomaten.
Wir mögen Kuchen.
Mögt ihr ein Stück Kuchen?
Sie mögen Luxus.
sein
Ich bin 18 Jahre alt.
Wie alt bist du?
Er ist krank.
Wir sind geschieden.
Seid ihr verheiratet?
Sie sind frisch verliebt.
haben
Ich habe einen Sohn.
Hast du Kinder?
Er, sie,
es hat eine schwere Krankheit.
Wir haben eine neue Wohnung.
Habt ihr Hunger?
Sie haben ein neues Auto.
nehmen
Ich nehme ein Medikament.
Was nimmst du?
Er, sie, es nimmt einen Kaffee.
Wir nehmen am Deutschkurs teil.
Nehmt ihr eure Kinder mit?
Sie nehmen den Preis entgegen.
Ich nehme ein heisses Bad.
Ich habe ein heisses Bad genommen.